bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors pourquoi ce
projet de fusion ne va pas dans le bon
sens
[Musique]
et là pendant bon sens puisque ce projet
va se traduire par la suppression de 300
lits c'est en contradiction totale avec
les promesses faites par monsieur
lacroix hier soir vous savez qu'un
rapport de la cour des comptes a
signifié à la semaine dernière que nous
avions trop peu de lits de réanimation
en france ce que nous dénonçons depuis
maintenant quinze ans nous les
urgentistes depuis 2003 depuis la
canicule
donc vouloir continuer les opérations du
monde d'avant c'est à dire des
restructurations hospitalières qui se
traduisent par des fermetures de lits
aujourd'hui c'est irresponsable et jeu
sera même plus sévère ce serait criminel
il faut maintenir ces hôpitaux parce que
sa vie les 10 mille lits de réanimation
promis par monsieur macro hier soir
c'est ce que nous avait promis monsieur
vers en juillet l'an dernier où sont ils
ces lits et il n'est pas question une
fois qu'on les a réouvert données fermé
il faudra les conserver et pour cela et
bien il faut des locaux
il faut embaucher du personnel est formé
du personnel ce qui n'a pas été fait ces
dernières années et ce qu'il n'a surtout
pas été fait de clients dans la gestion
globale de l'hôpital public quel bilan
vous en faites depuis le début de cette
pandémie
non
et bien quand on parle de guerre il faut
préparer ses armes une des armes et
l'hôpital rien n'a été fait à l'hôpital
1er janvier 2020 avant la crise cinq
mille lits de réanimation en france là
nous sommes aujourd'hui au mois de mars
nous sommes toujours à 5000 lits de
réanimation en urgence nous avons ouvert
quelques milliers lits supplémentaires
mais dans des conditions qui sont pas
acceptables en particulier pour les
malades n'ont qu'à vide que nous sommes
obligés déprogrammé et qui sont quand
même majoritaire
il ya plus de malades n'ont commis que
deux malades co lead et que ses patients
aujourd'hui soit déprogrammé c'est à
dire qu'on repousse leur prise en charge
à leur traitement
bon ça que ça aura une incidence sur
leur état de santé donc nous allons
passer d'une crise qui est géré au jour
le jour sans préparation sans
anticipation et surtout et bien il n'est
pas question que l'on revienne au monde
d'avant et nous demandons un moratoire
sur toutes les restructurations
hospitalières et en particulier celles
qui me concerne aujourd'hui c'est le
fameux l'hôpital nord avec la fermeture
des hôpitaux bichat et beaujon
juste pour vous dire que monsieur martin
hirsch ces dernières semaines plutôt que
de se préoccuper d'ouvrir des lits de
réanimation est allé devant le conseil
municipal de saint-ouen pour vendre son
projet c'est proprement scandaleux
ce monsieur est irresponsable nous le
disons clairement aujourd'hui il ya une
grande colère chez les soignantes parce
que le demander en urgence d'ouvert
délit alors que rien n'a été fait
pendant la période on avait une petite
marge de manoeuvre
l'été dernier c'est scandaleux c'est de
la préparation mais nous en avons assez
de ces dirigeants de cette politique
qui à la petite semaine qui nous met en
grande difficulté nous les soignons nous
sommes épuisés et en colère or justement
hier emmanuel macron lors de son
allocution vous l'avez peut-être écouté
s'est adressée aux personnels de santé
la demande et ses personnels de se
mobiliser encore plus
[Musique]
mais nous sommes déjà mobilisés ce que
nous demandons à monsieur macron c'est
pas de se mobiliser c'est qu'il nous
écoute et nous écouter s'est arrêté les
plans de restructuration former du
personnel et pour cela nous avons fait
des propositions
vous savez si nous avions ouvert les
écoles l'aide soignante il ya un an nous
aurions des aides soignantes qui serait
diplômés dans un mois si une partie de
mes collègues médecins n'avait pas
refusé d'augmenter le nombre d'un terne
en réanimation mois de novembre l'an
dernier nous aurions
75 interne aurait animation
supplémentaire aujourd'hui qui aura été
formés ces derniers mois et qu'ils
seraient disponibles en renfort dans les
services de réanimation
donc voilà donc il ya un véritable
problème c'est à dire que les gens là
qui réfléchissent à l'elysée
entouré par un certain nombre de
conseillers médecin conseil scientifique
etc
ils sont complètement coupés de la
réalité de terrain que ce que vivent les
soignants bon jour le jour et surtout
que les soignants le représentant
légitime cochon et syndicats ne soit pas
écouté
alors il ya justement des mesures de
confinement strict étendu à toute la
france qui ont été annoncés hier la
fermeture des écoles aussi haut que
pensez vous de ces mesures qui ont été
annoncées est ce que ce sera suffisant
pour faire baisser le nombre de malades
en réanimation puisqu'on a dépassé le
cap des 5000 maintenant
[Musique]
non ce ne sera pas suffisant vous savez
elles m'ont les mesures barrières sont
efficaces mais ce confinement qui n'en
est pas vraiment un
à une efficacité tout à fait limité vous
savez les seuls confinement qui ont
montré leur efficacité
c'est la méthode chinoise au sud
coréenne ou quand on est une île comme
la nouvelle-zélande et la nouvelle
calédonie
la solution aujourd'hui c'est
d'accélérer la vaccination et là je
crains le pire parce que depuis le mois
de février monsieur macro nous annonce
l'arrivée massive de vaccins que nous
n'avons toujours pas et ce qui est
particulier scandaleux c'est que
monsieur macro et la madame vers
l'arrière de la communauté européenne
ont demandé à leurs représentants lors
de la récente réunion de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce de voter contre la
résolution qui était présenté par
l'afrique du sud et l'inde est soutenu
par son pays d'une levée des brevets
donc on puisse avoir accès aux
formulations des vaccins et mettre en
production ces vaccins sont déçus si le
savez nous avons des usines en france
qui pourrait produire ce vaccin s'il y
avait une devait des brevets et 50 en
europe ce qui permettrait de produire
massivement des vaccins pour l'europe le
plus rapide de la planète parce
qu'aujourd'hui
écoutez c'est ridicule le nombre de
personnes vaccinées or la vaccination et
efficace moi je peux vous dire qu'au
quotidien
nous avons beaucoup moins quasiment plus
de personnes qui viennent d epal et
regarder la grande bretagne
j'apprenais l'arrière tout cas pour tout
le grand londres qui est une une ville
de la même taille que paris il y avait
eu un mort du co vide dans la journée
voilà donc la vaccination est efficace
il va falloir accélérer et nous avons
assez des promesses parce qu'aujourd'hui
les vaccins ne sont toujours pas là
merci beaucoup à vous christophe
prudhomme porte parole des médecins
urgentistes de france